[Música]
ideas pensamientos y sentimientos que
están desde aquí en mi corazón y mi
cabeza hacia afuera por mucho tiempo fue
uno de mis más grandes y mayores miedos
el tener algo dentro y querer sacarlo
es algo complicado es algo difícil pero
hoy hoy me doy cuenta que eso es
exactamente lo que marca nuestra
personalidad nuestro carácter y a partir
de ahí empieza todo
a mí me gustaría preguntarles para
ustedes qué es el miedo
y recuerdan la primera vez que lo
sintieron recuerdan la primera vez que
en su cuerpo experimentaron esa
sensación de miedo
el miedo según la ciencia
es una emoción caracterizada por una
intensa sensación desagradable provocada
por la percepción de un peligro real o
supuesto presente futuro o incluso
pasado
es una emoción primaria que se deriva de
la versión natural al riesgo oa la
amenaza qué quiere decir esto el miedo
es una emoción que experimentamos en
nuestro cuerpo cuando nos sentimos
amenazados cuando nos sentimos expuestos
a algo que verdaderamente no conocemos
cuándo es algo totalmente diferente y
fuera de nuestro ser
las personas lo pueden experimentar de
diferentes maneras
puede ser que tengas una opresión en tu
pecho puede ser que tengas una opresión
en tu estómago que te tiemble en las
manos que te duela la cabeza hay
diferentes maneras de experimentarlo
pero todos absolutamente todos el 100%
de las personas que estamos en este
lugar hemos sentido miedo alguna al
menos una sola vez en nuestra vida
y recuerdan la primera vez que lo
sintieron recuerdan la primera vez que
sintieron algo en su cuerpecito cuando
estábamos pequeñitos
qué es lo que cuál fue el momento que
era lo que estaba pasando en ese momento
en su vida que los hizo sentir eso hace
unos días un amigo me comentaba que la
primera vez que el sintió miedo fue
cuando estaba jugando con su hermanito y
deciden estaban como en una montaña de
tierra y deciden saltar y su hermanito
cae sobre un vidrio y se corta el pie y
ve muchísima sangre entonces él fue la
primera vez que experimentó esa
sensación de peligro que tal vez no era
en sí en su cuerpo pero estaba viendo
algo estaba viendo algo que lo provocaba
a sentir miedo otra persona me platicó
que la primera vez que lo sintió fue
cuando fue por primera vez al kinder y
se separó de su mamá soltó la mano de su
mamá y en ese momento sintió una una
sensación de vacío de miedo de soledad
todos los representamos de diferente
manera pero siempre existe en nuestra
vida
detrás de cada detrás de cada de cada
miedo hay un gran sueño
cuando tenía 19 años decidí empezar a
emprender un viaje de vida un viaje de
vida en el que encontré mi pasión
encontré el amor a crear postres y el
amor a las ventas claro que en este
transcurso y todo este proceso hubo
muchísimos episodios en los que sentí
mucho miedo
miedos simples desde
y no sé si el pastel me va a quedar tal
como debe de quedar o miedos como no sé
si voy a poder pagar la luz del lugar y
el sueldo para mis empleados
o miedos hasta no sé cómo voy a lidiar
con una clienta que está molesta y no
está satisfecha con lo que le estoy
entregando
todos estos miedos cambiaron mi vida y
forjaron mi personalidad y carácter de
una forma increíble
pero me di cuenta que los que marcaron
más
toda esta forma de ser fueron aquellos
que venía arrastrando desde que estaba
chiquitita todos aquellos que en algún
momento sentí cuando estaba pequeña y
empezaron a repercutir en mi presente
el otro día estaba en una tienda y me di
cuenta venía de las escaleras y venía un
señor con su niño agarrados de la mano
ellos venían ellos venían bajando y yo
venía subiendo entonces los estaba
observando y de pronto el niño venían
tranquilos agarrados de la mano y de
pronto el niño decide soltar a su papá y
correr
en su emoción de querer ir solo y con
todas las ganas y la energía del niño se
cae y se pega en su carita entonces el
niño regresa con su papá y llorando y
super triste de que se había lastimado
le dice papá me duele mi cara me pegue
me caí y el papá en su desesperación y
preocupación por el niño le dice
eso te pasa por querer ir solo
ouch yo lo único que pensé en ese
momento pensa dos cosas pensé que gran
dependencia está creando este hombre en
su hijo hacia él
y la otra era
tú le estás transmitiendo tu miedo le
estás transmitiendo un miedo a esa
personita
y de qué forma
de esta forma me doy cuenta de que el
miedo va en cadenas de que el miedo va
d
de diferentes de la misma familia va a
trascendiendo va acomodando se lo vamos
pasando
y esto hace que cuando estás niño
cuántas veces a nosotros de chiquitos
nos dijeron sabes que no lo hagas tú
porque no puedes porque está chiquito
porque estás pequeño lo voy a hacer yo
esto es algo muy complicado no saltes
ahí porque te vas a caer y te vas a
pegar y creo que todas estas ideas que
nos fueron imponiendo desde pequeños
hicieron que tuviéramos diferentes tipos
de miedo a largo
a lo largo de nuestras vidas y lo que
menos quiero es juzgar al papá no estoy
en esa posición de decir la mejor
respuesta hubiera sido otra
lo que quiero es que hagamos conciencia
de que es muy importante que son muy
importantes nuestras palabras lo que
transmitimos lo que decimos y trabajar
con nuestros miedos trabajar con aquello
que venimos arrastrando desde antes de
qué forma podemos enfrentar nuestros
miedos tengo tres puntos que considero
que son los importantes para trabajar
con nuestros miedos
el primero el primero es identificarlo
podemos ponernos a pensar si ya saben en
el momento en el que identificaron en el
que sintieron por primera vez un miedo
pueden identificar en su cuerpo cuál es
la sensación que les provoca es muy
probable que esa misma sensación en el
presente es lo que es lo que sientan de
esa manera lo podemos identificar si
recordamos alguna situación pongamos un
ejemplo estoy en mi oficina
y trabajando y de pronto llega a una
persona y me dice sabes que no hagas
todo el trabajo mejor luego yo creo que
a mí me quedaría mejor que a ti
y en ese momento sientes como miedo
sientes no no no no sé si lo puedo hacer
tal vez y tal vez no bueno que lo haga
ella y si te pones a pensar tal vez en
el infancia tu papá y tu mamá en algún
momento te pudieron haber dicho sabes
que no lo hagas tú lo hago yo yo puedo
tú tranquila y a lo mejor su intención
no era lastimarte su intención no era
hacerte pensar que no podías pero tal
vez pero si creó una especie de miedo no
y eso repercute en el presente de esa
manera podemos identificar qué es lo que
pasó que me estaba haciendo pasar
ahorita algo identificarlo para podernos
para poder dejarnos sentir
últimamente el agua el agua me ha dado
muchos mensajes me ha hecho aprender
el otro día fui a un río y mientras
estaba viendo el río había una parte en
donde el agua corría y fluía donde no
había obstáculos donde no había basura y
el agua estaba cristalina estaba limpia
y corriendo y había otra parte en donde
había piedras en donde había basura en
donde había ramas que no permitía fluir
el agua y creo que ahí es cuando
conectamos con lo real con la naturaleza
con lo que somos de dónde venimos cuando
nos damos cuenta de que de esa manera
funcionamos de que tenemos que fluir
tenemos que dejar sentir nuestras
emociones para que puedan para que
podamos crecer pienso que el miedo nos
transforma o nos destruye cuando lo
tomamos de forma positiva nos transforma
y cuando lo tomamos de forma negativa
nos destruye nosotros decidimos si
avanzamos o nos quedamos
el otro punto es aceptarlo una vez que
lo identificamos podemos dejarlo sentir
podemos dejar que pase no hacerlo parte
de nosotros simplemente que entre lo
sentimos y lo dejamos salir y de esa
forma podemos empezar a aceptarlo
los propósitos del miedo creo que todo
en la vida tiene un propósito todo
estaba ahí por algo el miedo
necesariamente está ahí porque hay algo
que te está anunciando hay algo hay un
poquito no está por nada un poquito rojo
ahí diciéndote sabes que aquí estoy
mírame estoy aquí por algo tiene que
estar ahí por algo tiene un propósito de
nuestra vida te puede ayudar a conocerte
a ti mismo puedo ayudar a conocer las
emociones que tienes que está sintiendo
frente a alguna situación y por ende te
ayuda a fortalecer tus debilidades te
ayuda a crecer te ayuda a entenderte a
ti mismo y de esa manera fluir
y ahí es cuando considero que
que el miedo puede formar un canal hacia
el amor
desde hace tiempo me di cuenta de que
conforme va pasando el tiempo y vas
creando miedos y vas viviendo
situaciones
que no acepta así que no tolera así que
prefiero es poner una capa empezamos a
poner cápitas en nuestro corazón una
tras otra y esto es a lo que yo llamo un
corazón de cebolla un corazón de cebolla
en el que vas poniendo capas protectoras
innecesarias que no tienen que estar ahí
y es importante que identifiquemos
cuáles son nuestros miedos que
identifiquemos de dónde viene que lo
hizo que lo provocó para que el momento
de que sepamos de dónde viene podamos
trabajar lo podamos sanarlo e ir
quitando una y otra y otra capa hasta
tener nuestro corazón sano sostener
nuestro corazón protegido pero sin capas
innecesarias y creo que ahorita es súper
importante que lo hagamos para poder
hacer un cambio para poder hacer una
mejora en el mundo en mil áreas y más
que nada por aquellos niños aquellos
pequeñitos que apenas acaban de pisar o
que vienen en camino para poder dar como
una protección que verdaderamente es
necesaria y un corazón fuerte gracias
[Aplausos]